hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Kashima Memorial
Tournament it's actually a game from
round two we already said if there will
be a slow ground round for seems a bit a
bit slow so I haven't decided if I was
showing any games from round four yet
but until then it's a very nice game
Dingley and versus Alexander Greece
shook as you've requested I do
understand why I requested and it's
really a beauty so without further ado
let's just check it out dink has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have Knight to f6 c4
we have g6 and now f3 the the anteroom
fold
we have c5 by agree shook with d5 d6 and
II for going for the Benoni type
structure we have e six by Black Knight
to c3 and now after an exchange in the
center captures captures how we go into
the main line of the benoni defense now
and okay Bishop to g7 with Knight g2e to
biding Knight bt7 and now Knight to g3
and here being is basically repeating
the the same line Grisha already played
with the white with the black pieces in
the 2000 and 2018 candidates tournament
Grisha had this position against Levon
Aronian and it's a it's it's a similar a
similar line after h5 this is also what
Grisha played again starting on Bishop
to e2 was played Knights the h7 now and
here
Bishop to f4 was played by onion and
that game was drawn between English
canary but here
ding has a different idea instead of the
software for he goes Knights to f1 and
this move was never played before it is
already in this move from move 11 that
we have a completely new game and for
foreign opening as old as the Benoni
it's always interesting to have a new
game already on move 11 so ok Queen to
h4 check immediately by grey suit now if
you go Knight back to g3 just block with
the knight then black is just gonna go
Queen 7 and it's like you wasted the
move you lost the tempo it's like your
knight remained on g3 and the black had
2 moves here it's like he played a
knight h7 and Queen to e7 so not
something you want to do so this is what
being prepared he played the g3 now
Queen goes back
the e7 ends now night the e3 the night
is riemann over to the e3 square grisha
castles and now we have a four Knights
the e5 body shop and now castles riding
just you know bring his king over to
safety and basically inviting Bishop to
h3 which agree should be immediately
employs we have looked he won and now
comes look 88 and with this rook 88
Grigio basis basically finishes
development of his pieces you still have
to figure out what to do with the knight
and age 7 but your other pieces are you
know doing pretty excellently and this
is what ding wanted with the white piece
he wanted to create something that was
never played before and now he's looking
for his chances I haven't I haven't seen
the interview after the game so I don't
know how far dings preparation went but
I would be very interested to hear it
Bishop to b2 by ding now comes a 6 and
rook to a3 a very nice rook lifts that
that can be used to guard the 3rd rank
but also it can be used as an attacking
resource or for example rook to be 2 can
be played going after the b7 pawn so
here Queen to c7 by black and now comes
f4 a very nice idea by ding I think by
this point ding is still well inside his
preparation here you have to go Bishop
to g4 it seems like an ugly ugly move
because the white is attacking that
square three times and you will lose a
pawn but the alternative is no better
here Grisha instead went back Knight to
d7 and usually the hardest move to find
is with the knight back but here here
it's not the case here the knight and e7
now blocks the retreat square of the
bishop on h3 all the other squares are
taken as you can see by the white pawns
and well okay g4 isn't taken but you
will still lose lose upon so here ding
just goes for Bishop captures on h5 and
it's a very nice idea if pawn captures
then Queen captures and now g4 square is
taken by the Queen all of these squares
are taken the bishop has nowhere to
retreat and you will just win the piece
and remain with extra pawns
so after a bishop characters on h5 with
for creating the c5 outpost for tonight
so the bishop can retreat and ding just
moves the best road back we have Bishop
to f3 so by switching the the line a bit
from the candidates game that our Grisha
played again starring and Bing is
already up upon unmov'd 21 okay nice to
see five now the bishop does retreat
square Queen to c2 bringing another
defender to the e4 pawn and now comes
Knight to b3 and it's a it's a very
dangerous move because it's an excellent
outpost for the Black Knight the rook is
now has nowhere to go you always have to
keep an eye on the Knight captures
Bishop and it's the knife just
disappeared sorry
and well it's just a wonderful position
but here a very interesting line is
Knight captures on c4 but it's not good
for white your idea is okay if black
captures I'm just gonna sorry I'm just
gonna capture the knight on B 3 but here
black goes night here first with an
attack on the Queen and the bishop and
the bishop is not defended so here you
would have to go Queen d3 Knight
captures with Czech Queen captures and
now Queen captures on c4 and okay
you didn't win a piece because after g4
the bishop is trapped but still black
black always comes up on top after b5
captures captures you are threatening B
for now and after the knight moves let's
say Knight to d1 you play B for the rook
has to move and the bishop to d4 is
coming it's it's just a very very
dangerous align for whites to play black
would be better here so after Knight to
b3 ding just played rook captures on V 3
and this is what's nice and chest if
you're up upon you can just give up the
exchange to grab another pawn then you
will be down the exchange but you will
be up to pawns which is a very nice
conversation in itself so C captor son
b3 was played Queen captures and b3
biding and now King to h8 and here we
have night C 2 D 1 G for g4 is
interesting but it will not work for
example if you try to go after the
bishop with the king black will just go
f5 and the possible escape and you will
weaken your king side position a bit too
much so here Dean finds another way to
go after
he plays night c2d one he go he's
preparing night 2 f2 so the bishop will
have to move with f5 and only now nice
to f2 the bishop is under attack but the
Greek first captures on e4 we have pawn
captures Bishop captures on e4 and now
Bishop to fi finally the bishop moves
and you hear a ding doesn't want to
clear the e-file well his own rook
occupies de Falla so first looked the c1
he attacks the queen forces the Queen to
move but also he's planning rook
Seaforth to be for to go after the b7
pawn he definitely doesn't want to allow
Grisha cookster to become active
so Queen to d7 and now Bishop back to f3
he's not interested in any trades he
just wants to play rook c4 rug before we
have Knight to f6 Bishop now tries to
activate his night and now rook the c4
which is just an excellent move you know
a multi-purpose move as it prepares room
before but also adds another defender to
d4 square you don't want to allow moves
like Knight to e4
so Queen to e7 and now comes Knight
captures on f5g captures on f5 and King
to g2 just not allowing any any
weaknesses to remain in the in White's
camp rook the c8 offering a trade but
now just rook the B for going after an
attack here and look to c7 and here just
a5 not allowing the the weak b7 pawn to
be put forward and here at Grace who
plays a very interesting move which
creates a lot of complications he plays
Knight to d7 and it's it's interesting
because rook captures on b7 is
definitely a possibility but what
happens after real captures and b7 is is
very interesting route captures Queen
captures and now rook to b8 you have
forced the Queen to move Queen captures
on a6
rook captures on b2 and this is where
the magic happens most likely well I'm
sure I'm sure being calculated all of
this out but there's a very nice line
for white here in this position Bishop
c3 you force a trade of dark square
bishop and after Bishop captures now you
just pick it up
Queen c8 check you pick up the bishop
King gauge 7 Queen captures and here
rook a to putting Droog behind
spawn you would have this position where
black is still up the exchange but white
is up three pawns and he does have he
already has two to pass pawns it would
be a better a better position for white
but it's hard to say if it would be
enough to win
ding decides it's not enough to win so
he doesn't capture first he prepares a
rush up to d1
he wants to after he captures and the
rook you know crashes down on b2 he
wants to be able to block the attack
towards the dark square Bishop wood
Bishop to see - it's ok Queen to f7 by
Europe and only now rook captures on b7
with rook captures Queen captures and
now rook to b8 and here not capturing
the point but first rooked Queen to c6
preparing to capture here we have rook
captures on b2 and now
Queen to Bishop - C - this is why he
didn't capture on a6 he wanted the Queen
to be guarding the bishop on c2 we have
Bishop to d4 now also a rook to be far
was a possibility just bring the roof to
a nice active square pressure the d5
pawn but here he has a different plan he
plays Bishop to d4 and here we have
Knights to d3 attacking the rook and
it's a very interesting move because I
have to look to a - you could play Queen
to c4 which comes up with a double
attack against the bishop and against
the rock on a - so after night to d3
Grisha decides to give a wealth to offer
back the exchange by playing Queen to e7
now if you capture you allow the Queen
to you know jump down on e2 and start an
attack so first King to f1 being doesn't
know how it and now agree she runs back
with the rook we have rook to b8 and now
night Stewie 1/3 maneuvering the knight
to f3 and from there the night can be
used to attack the black King Knights
the c5 by Ashok now comes Knight to f3
and Bishop the back to f6 just
controlling the f3 Knight with this
opposition very nicely and Bishop
captures on f5 by dink
rook goes back to b3 with an attack not
there but we don't attack against the
knight on f3
Queen to see a to check with King to g7
and now come
Knight to g5 offering the night and you
do have to capture it it's it's it's
quite a quite a poisonous position if
you try something like Queen's Queen d8
well with the idea of changing Queens
you have ideas like Queen captures and
c5 lurking because after pawn captures
you can go 96 check pick up the Queen
let's taking f7 captures with check you
will capture the night and after Bishop
d6 you will just have a lot of pressure
work to all of these backbones you know
just marching forward
so after this Knight to g5 movie she
decides to capture it with Bishop
captures and g5f captures and g5 and now
again Grisha has to decide how he wants
to play this he's not interested in in
something like 25 and I centralizing
move which would pretty much offer up
drawing chances let's say after Queen to
c7 if we go King f8 Queen ch-check you
could just be repeating moves in G 727
check goodie shop is not interested in
something like that he wants to start an
attack rook to f3 with check we have
King to g2 and now Queen to eat you with
check King to h3 and now again you could
try something like Queen to e5 sorry
about that I'll be back in in just one
second
oh sorry about that I'm back I just had
to open the door so after Queen to e5
which could be an ideal move just an or
again a nice centralizing move again you
could go for something like Queen c7
chair King f8 Bishop to g4 just not even
going for a draw white could even be
better here
so here Grisha decides to go for a
different idea he gives up the rook for
two pieces we have rook captures on f5
Queen captures on f5 and now Queen
captures on details so here Grisha is up
a knight but he's down three points and
those pawns are very close to the black
king especially the g5 pawn
so here what ding does is first Queen f6
check King g8 and now Queen g6 check
King to h8 and now Queen captures on d6
going after the knight and c5 so as
there are no checks to be given to the
white king white the black first has to
deal with how to how to defend the night
you could defend it with the Queen
Grisha decides to go for Knights to d3
we to h6 check getting the Queen out of
the way so the the past D pawn can be
pushed forward we have King to g8 and
now Queen to e6 check King to g7 Queen
to e7 check King to g8 and now comes d6
so you do have to deal with this past
pawn and it's not all that clear how you
will do it but white also has to defend
Grisha who goes nice to have to check
King to h4 and now comes the Queen to d4
check we have king to h5 and now Queen
to d1 check and here again a very
interesting position you have to play it
precisely if you play something like
King to h6
then black can get an easy draw 94 check
now you either go into some discoveries
or you go King g6 now Queen d3 check
King back to h5 and now Queen to f5 and
it's not it's not all that clear how you
will avoid any checks if you try
something like something like Queen to
d8 check you could go King h7 Queen c7
check you would go King g8 and you will
just have to keep on checking because
well you don't want to you don't want to
allow black
any moves you can even get to checkmate
for example if you try something like d7
just Knight f6 check is perfectly fine
either King h4 will follow Queens you
for checkmate or if you go to h6 Queen
to h7 checkmate so you have to play this
very precisely g4 amazingly this is the
move that the only move that works for
white and the Dean calculates precisely
because if Queen captures on g4 then you
go King to g6 and you don't have a
defense against the checkmate well you
could defend it with something like
queenie forecheck but then just Queen
captures on e4 Knight captures and
there's no stopping the the past deep on
so after g4 you cannot capture with the
Queen Bishop captures with the night and
okay now you do have some nasty
discoveries inside but it doesn't work
I'll let you and decide how to play this
position on it's not all the difficult
so I'm not even gonna wait for you to
pause the video I'm just gonna have a
nice sip of my water of course now you
pick up the night and this is the only
chance black had queenie a check or
queen e6 immediately
ding decides to go queenie a check he
wants to force the King back from the
from the back rank King g7 now Queen d7
check King to h8 and now he picks it up
Queen captures here white of black of
course cannot afford to trade Queen so
he captures the past pawn and here dink
was able to win back the piece but he
still up two points so I mean in a queen
and pandian game being up two points is
a pretty big deal we have Queen to c8
Quinta CA twit check King to g7 and now
comes Queen to c3 with check King to h7
Queen to c2 check King to g7 and now h4
the two connected passports are now
going forward
Queen to e6 hoping to deliver at least
some checks about the Queen to c7 check
with King to h8 and now Queen to d8
check King to h7 Queen to c7 check
repeating repeating once just you know
to for some reason
sometimes people just do this and now
Queen to b6 of course black
cannot trade and you do have a few
checks available to you but first the
Queen to c4 check defending the a sex
pawn we have Queen to d8 with check King
to g7 and now Queen to e7 check King to
g8 and now comes King to h6 and okay now
the king is creating a wall here against
the against the black king queen t8 is
the threat of checkmate also Queen to g7
is the threat of checkmate black has to
deal with this Queen to c6 check
we have g6 now and now Queen to c1 check
we have Queen to g5 Queen to d1 now and
here there should be still not resigning
because there's still hope some hope but
you know the thing is not 2,800 2,800
plus 4 without a reason
rubber again feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the cleanest
way to win this with the white pieces
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finisher of games and for those of you
who played something like g7 you will
not be winning this game because now
black can actually draw this for example
Queen d6 check Queen g6 blocking Queen
back the d2 check you can now block back
Queen g5 Queen b6 check and if you try
something like King to h5 the problem is
now black has this resource of going
Queen g6 and now are you a leader go to
g4 and black will continue checking you
or you will capture the Queen with the
king or the Queen and you will still
meet the black King so now there was of
course this possibility of being was
being hasty or something but you know
ding doesn't rush things he just calmly
played Queen to f4 and it was in this
position I moved 77 that Alexander
leadership resigned the game what if you
resign well now there's the obvious
threat of checkmate you could go Queen
b8 check Queen f7 check followed by
something like Queen g7 or h7 checkmate
so here once you stop 1 let's say you go
here prevented this one you will face
something like Queen d4 and again
threaten all sorts of checkmates and
after you stop one of them you will get
one end for example Queen d8 will be
checkmated there's no way out of this
how about their English we do not wait
for it after Queen to afford he resigned
the game so a lot of very interesting
moments in this game I agree shocker
twice he didn't want to go into and ROI
position with that Queen e5 Knight
centralizing move he wanted to beat
thing he went all out on an attack with
the black pieces that's how real chess
is played and we should all congratulate
the guruship on this game as well as
doing because you don't create a game
like this by yourself if your opponent
is not interested in at least trying to
beat you then you know most likely the
game would have been drawn but yeah this
is how real chess is played and I'm very
happy I got to show this game on my
channel so I would like to thank Michael
Hildebrand David McKeever Darvin then
Boyle Jaime Reyes and Silvia Stephan for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos serie
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content thank you and I will
see you soon